so nah ist kein anderes schwarzes loch
der erde es wiegt nur drei sonnenmassen
und wurde jetzt entdeckt es liegt nur
1500 lichtjahre von der erde entfernt
was wissen wir also über diesen winzigen
und kann dieses schwarze loch der erde
und dem leben hier gefährlich werden
klicks umsatz im flugzeug gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
aufgespürt wurde das schwarze loch im
orbit um den mars erreichen riesenstern
mit der bezeichnung v 723 mond und
dieser rotary sie ist schon länger dafür
bekannt dass seine helligkeit schwankt
und sich seine licht kurve somit
regelmäßig verändern das schwarze loch
verbirgt sich im sternbild des mono
zeros übersetzt so viel wie ein horn das
ist auch der grund warum das schwarze
loch selbst nun den spitznamen für
unicorn also das einhorn trägt und
dieses schwarze loch ist der erde für
astronomische verhältnisse sogar
ziemlich nahe
1500 lichtjahre trennen uns doch warum
konnte das schwarze loch erst jetzt
aufgespürt werden und kann es dem leben
auf der erde gefährlich werde die
antworten auf diese spannenden fragen
gibt es in diesem video fest steht es
handelt sich um einen echten winzling
denen die fachleute jetzt entdeckt haben
trotzdem sollte man ihm nicht so nahe
kommt er ist halt ein alles
verschlingende schwarzes loch einhorn
ist etwa dreimal so schwer wie unsere
sonne und das ist im vergleich zu
anderen schwarzen löchern eher klein für
das forschungsteam von der ohio
university war der fund des winzlings
also eine große überraschung das
schwarze loch ist aber nicht nur
besonders klein sondern auch unsichtbar
und zur zeit inaktiv und genau deswegen
konnte es sich so lange versteckt halten
ganz alleine seine schwerkraft hat es
dann am schluss verraten denn diese
beeinflusst die bahn seines begleiters
des roten riesen v 723 mond mit seiner
entdeckung sind die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler einem großen rätsel
der astrophysik auf der spur
denn bislang ist unklar wie klein ein
schwarzes loch wirklich sein kann fest
steht nur ein stellares schwarzes loch
entsteht dann wenn ein massereicher
stern zu einer supernova explodiert
ende seines lebenszyklus je nach masse
kollabiert der stern kann dann entweder
zu einem extrem dichten neutronenstern
oder aber zu einem schwarzen loch doch
wo liegt hier die grenze ein schwieriges
rätsel für astronomen und astronomen
weltweit denn kleine inaktive schwarze
löcher sind unsichtbar und das auch für
die besten messinstrumente sie sind
nicht einmal unbedingt aufzuspüren wenn
sie teil eines doppel systems sind nicht
einmal in solchen fällen ist die
existenz solcher nicht aktiv materie
einen saugenden schwarzen löcher zum
verhalten ihrer partner zu erkennen
bislang wissen fachleute also weder wie
viele sich von ihnen in der milchstraße
befinden noch welche massen sie
aufweisen also es könnte noch viel mehr
auch hier in der nähe der erde geben wir
haben hier ja schon öfter darüber
berichtet dass schwarze löcher wegen
ihrer und auffindbarkeit auch im
verdacht stehen die dunkle materie zu
bilden so viele könnten es nämlich sein
aufgespürt werden konnte ein horn wie
oben schon angedeutet einzig und alleine
durch das verhalten seines begleiters
denn die bewegung des roten riesen
sterns wird durch die schwerkraft des
schwarzen lochs beeinflusst eine
unsichtbare kraft also die an dem roten
riesen zieht und zerrt zudem war der
riesenstern v7 23 mohn in der fachwelt
schon lange als veränderlicher sterne
mit schwanken der helligkeit bekannt
doch warum veränderte sich seine licht
kurve so regelmäßig um diese fragen zu
klären hatte das us forschungsteam die
beobachtungsdaten von verschiedenen
teleskopen genauer ins visier genommen
dabei waren unter anderem die
bewegungsdaten des kia satelliten der
esa und die spektral daten der nasa
teleskops trifft und test so kamen die
fachleute letztendlich darauf dass der
rote riese einen unsichtbaren begleiter
haben muss und dessen schwerkraft muss
enormen einfluss auf den roten riesen
nahmen das legten sowohl die analyse des
lichtspektrums als auch die daraus
ermittelte radialgeschwindigkeit und
form des roten riesen nah vereinfacht
gesagt zieht also eine unsichtbare kraft
an dem roten riesen eine art gezeiten
verzerrung wie wir sie hier auch von der
erde kennen hier löst der mond ja die
gezeiten im meer aus dazu sagt einer der
beteiligten wissenschaftler top thompson
so wie die schwerkraft des mondes die
ozeane der erde verzerrt und die meere
zum mond hinzieht und ebbe und flut
erzeugt verzerrt das schwarze loch den
stern in eine ovale form wobei eine
achse länger als die andere ist demnach
muss es sich um ein kompaktes aber
dunkles objekt handel mit sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit also ein schwarzes
loch dazu schreiben die forschenden wir
fanden keinerlei hinweise auf einen
licht emittierenden begleiter und können
auch einen haupt rein sternen oder einen
stern paar als begleit objekt
ausschließen als wir uns die daten
anschauten sprang uns dieses schwarze
loch geradezu ins auge
und tatsächlich eine zweite messung hat
die existenz von einhorn schon
bestätigen können ein weiteres
forschungsteam aus japan hat dazu die
radialgeschwindigkeit des roten riesen
noch einmal genauer unter die lupe
genommen
gemeint ist hiermit die geschwindigkeits
komponente bei einer kreisbewegung die
vom kreis mittelpunkt nach außen weist
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler untersuchten die
bestimmten unregelmäßigkeiten in der
licht kurve mit der hilfe eines modells
und fanden so heraus dass dies mit dem
gezeigten effekt des schwarzen lochs auf
dem roten riesen zu tun hat ein konzert
tatsächlich so stark am stern dass sich
hier eine wandernde ausbeulung befindet
dazu schreibt das japanische
forschungsteam die periodischen effekte
in der radialgeschwindigkeit von 723
mond lassen sich durch die gezeigten
bedingte deformation des sterns und die
damit verknüpften verzerrungen der
absorptions linien quantitativ erklären
zudem konnte auch die extrem geringe
masse von einer durch die zweite studie
bestätigt werden seine 2,93 sonnenmassen
lassen ist zu den kleinsten je
beobachteten schwarzen löchern gehören
es befindet sich somit in der
sogenannten masse lücke gemeint ist hier
mit der bereich in dem die grenze
zwischen neutronensternen und schwarzen
löchern liegt schwarze löcher in diesem
masse bereich sind bislang nur sehr
wenige bekannt die neue entdeckung zeigt
also dass die fachleute recht hatten mit
ihrer annahme dass es schwarze löcher in
dieser winzigen form geben muss doch
tatsächlich ist das etwas das die
astronomen astronomen erst seit kurzer
zeit für möglich halten demnach könnte
es sich bei einhorn um das kleinste und
zudem auch ehrt nächste schwarze loch
handeln was bislang aufgespürt werden
konnte erst im vergangenen jahr
2020 hatte ein forschungsteam im
doppelsternsystem hr 6 819 hinweise auf
ein stellares schwarzes loch gefunden
nur 1000 lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt doch weitere untersuchungen und
beobachtungen konnten das nicht
bestätigen
die hoffnung der fachleute ist groß
jetzt weitere winzlinge aufzuspüren und
so mehr erkenntnisse über das leben und
sterben eines sterns zu erfahren wie
wann und unter welchen umständen genau
endet der kollaps eines massereichen
sterns wann entsteht dabei ein schwarzes
loch und wann ein neutronenstern die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sind überzeugt davon das ist in unserer
galaxie noch weitere kleine schwarze
löcher gibt allein in solchen
doppelsternsystem die wie 723 mohn aus
riesenstern und inaktiven schwarzen
löchern bestehen könnte es in der
galaxie hundert bis tausend geben so die
schätzungen der fachleute neu
entwickelte teleskope und spektrografen
die über präziser werden könnten dabei
helfen weitere solcher winzlinge zu
offenbaren
die große frage aber die über allem
steht könnte ein horn und andere kleine
schwarze löcher der erde gefährlich
werden könnte es möglicherweise sogar
die gesamte erde verschlucken feststeht
schwarze löcher bringen den tod und der
appetit von schwarzen löchern kann
gigantisch sein ihr größtes talent
materie aufsaugen wenn es keine materie
rund um ihr schwerefeld mehr gibt warten
sie geduldig bis sie wieder zuschlagen
können und die enorme schwerkraft dieser
massemonster sorgt dafür dass immer
wieder nahe sterne oder gaswolken in
ihren gravitations strudel geraten wenn
ein stern in der nähe eines schwarzen
lochs gerät wird dieser durch die
enormen gezeitenkräfte
auseinandergerissen das schwarze loch
saugt es ohne erbarmen auf das
forschungsteam schließt dennoch aus dass
das kleine schwarze loch name ist eine
gefahr für uns werden kann
denn es hat keinen einfluss auf unser
sonnensystem bedingt durch seine kleine
größe zudem ist es dafür auch zu weit
von uns entfernt und selbst wenn unser
sonnensystem mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
auf ein solches schwarzes loch direkt zu
rasen würde würde es noch tausende jahre
bis zu einem zusammenstoß dauern
die gefahr die von stellaren schwarzen
löchern ausgeht ist also extrem gering
bei dem supermassiven schwarzen löchern
allerdings könnte das ganz anders
aussehen und hier wissen wir bereits
dass die galaxie die uns am nächsten
liegt ein großes schwarzes loch aufweist
und genau mit diesem nachbarn befindet
sich unsere galaxie mitsamt der erde auf
kondition
was dennoch nicht wirklich einen grund
zur aufregung denn fraglich ist zum
einen ob es überhaupt zu der kollision
mit dem schwarzen noch selbst kommt was
ja nur ein kleiner teil dieser galaxie
ist zudem wird das ganze noch ewigkeiten
dauern und die menschheit wird dieses
worst-case-szenario ganz sicher nicht
miterleben falls es denn überhaupt man
eintritt doch vorher wird sich die sonne
so stark erwärmen und sich ausdehnen und
letztendlich zur zerstörung der erde
film bevor überhaupt ein schwarzes loch
diese möglichkeit haben sollte schwarze
löcher erklären die dunkle materie
schwarzes loch in unserem sonnensystem
wie schwarze löcher gibt es viel öfter
als angenommen und eben vielleicht auch
direkt vor unserer haustür also dieses
video anklicken anschauen und diesen
kanal klicks uns als in future
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran